Hello, everybody! My name is Markiflavanav *Markiplier ex. stopped working. Sorry about that :/
Oh it's so pretty! Who are you?? Hi!
I punched her?! I punched her so hard she went into the ocean! I didn't mean it come back! I'm so sorry! *one punch*
It's a BDSM alligator! A BDSM-a-gator....It's a- it's a- Gimpagator *kinky*
It's a gu- *sigh*  It's a gimpi- It's an Alligimper
It's- it's a bee- It's an Allibee-D- yes *defeat*
Heeey! I'm sorry! I'm sorry that I punched the only woman on this island! *she ded dude*
Hello??
You like my horse ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *one punch*
Oh, I can walk with my huMAN legs!
OH! I can try to not to spi-hill my huMAN coffee! Is this how hard it is to actually human? (yes)
Oh key card?
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
The key cards in ma butt!
Ah, merci b-bequoo!  Merci...baquaaaaaaaa *flawless*
Game: Magnifique!
Frenchiplier: Ah, baguette! Un Eiffel Tower eeeugggh
*doink*
Get outta- stop dying!!
I'm not responsible for all of these deaths, you know. *sure mark* I'm not going to be labeled a murderer
Just because I'm rampantly pooing off my- oh. That baby caught a faceful
Um...excuse me? Could you get out of my horse *dirty*
Heng on...dun worry...I god it!...hendred persent!!
Innit 2 win it!!!11! Just gotta bow.. you know, every once in a while, pay my respects to the dead
You know, spill out some coffee for those that we have lost in this endeavor *rip*
Nut kick to the- whoa
Whoa, sorry!
Are you okay??
Your leg doesn't seem-
*Mark processes this fuckery*
DEMON!!!!!
Okay, anyway, I'm gonna go to Chuffington's
Frenchiplier: Ungh, lotion, keeps your skin soft and supple....eugh
It also...sounds a lot like farts...*giggle* But we French, are too polite for farts
Woah! Dat's nur-fur-dur-fur DAW FUN!!!!!
Raaah! Give me that! I'm so close! It's so tantalizing CLOSE!!
*Glitch*
*Dark? oh shit*
Put my castle... on this. Hell yes. I'm doin' all that with my brain! (that's a surprise)
I'm putting 'em all piece together, with my miiiind
*one punch*
Heh, I'm chargin' up ma poo!
What?
Santa, there we go, right on your ding dong (he didn't consent!!)
Santaplier: Browah! I dun wanna go!!
Santa you'll come with me whether you like it or not
Santaplier: Bwasannrfs!!
Shut up, Santa *rude*
Frenchiplier: Hep...oh-hon-hon-hon it fits like a gluhve!
*Markiplier had a stroke*
*Strokeiplier*
IMINIT2WINIT
Can I drive this car? (You're not old enough)
I can?! Really?!
Oh yes! Cinematic view for the car!
What am I gonna do with it? Where am I gonna drive it? Here I go! Off in the world blue yonder!
Haaaaugh! Ho, shit!
What are you doing? Why do you have a magic ranking? Why is there a fly? (all the questions but none of the time)
Why is there a guy in an ice-cream sandwich suit? (Hi Ethan) Years left on Earth, what does that even mean?!
This doesn't make any cents! (puns!1)
Frenchiplier: J-Yeah, whatever screw you. I don't know what you called me but I'm very UPset
Mm.. back that ass up... firetruck
*Hyuck* I'd like to think this is actually- Ooooh geeeeeez! Okay, goodbye, hello!
Oh, you want to put up your dukes? Well? I'll warn you, apparently I'm a great- ooookay. You're dead now
'Scuse me sir...where's this...
I heard there was a flash sale, or is it fart sale?? *ba dum tss* Heh, heh, you get me? You feelin me?
Okay, never mind then *rip*
The beam of light is not where I was it's where I'm pooping, and somehow- Oh there's poop in my sou-
Oh my God, did he die?! Oh he broke his long neck! (#mark'sthickneck)
Ho, oh, oh, oh oh, oh, hohohohohoho! *overcome by giggles*
Ooh! Oh okay there's other controls! Yeahahahaha! Get it! Get it man!
Gehehet it! *gasp* Get it!! Yeah!! YYyYeeEaAhH!!!
Hello! Can I trade on you? Yeeees. Oh you gallop so silly! Ohohohoho you're so silly
*horse mating sounds*
Hallo horsey- NYEHhuhuhuhuhuhu
There we go...aah you're welcome! Thank you. I'm a pu-huh (wut)
Lady, I got a Whaah. Can you give me a Whaah?? I've got a whole lot of whaah
Got some Whaaah! Anybody want some Whaah? Whaah? Can I get the Wheeerah?!
Lower it... oh, oh! Oh...lower it...looower it...*orgasm*
Okay, let's try to get through it, like this. Yeah, that's normal! Mmm!
My normal human walking pose! Yes!
Have a good day lovely fellow humans! Let me just journey my massive booty through the turnstile!
Well now I want to question a lot of things in life, in fact
I live a very abnormal life so I don't know- I mean not this abnormal. I'm not stretching myself out with lotion every night (That's what Amy's for)
Shut up.
Oh flash-sale! Exactly where I'm going, everybody get out of my way if you get one of my TVs
I swear to God I'm gonna rip out your eyebrows! (uh say again?) I'ma rip your eyebrows out apparently
*Strokeiplier strikes again*
Give give give give give give give give give
MIIIIIIINE!!!!!
*Diddly-doot-doot! Diddly-doot-doot!*
Ah fug WHY????!!!!
Can I get this? Can I get some of this? Delicious perfum
What $500?? You got to be eating my asshole! That's so stupid! -Original quote by Mark Edward Fishbach
Eh...get it up- Ah fuck! Lean back, raise it, raise it
Oh shit, we're getting the terminal ass extension (I don't think mark is doin okay)
Back it up....dah hah!
Okay, trying to make it like this now..normal human- Ah fuck!!
*PAAARRRTTTYYYY*
Ooooh! YEAH!! 420 blaze it!!
YEAAAAAH!!!
My windows open...(ah crap) My neighbor's been hearing me this whole time scream about poop...crap
(Check out more videos from this guy! He's a dork but he has 17 million subscribers so he has to be doin' something right!)